hey guys Mary here with gamespot
presenting the mix at GDC 2016 we have
all sorts of awesome indie games because
we're gonna showing you guys throughout
the day and i'm here with Colin from two
tribes you're going to show me in game
that I thought last year at PAX East
that we actually fell in love with its
call dr and this game is actually pretty
polished and pretty close to coming out
this is a right around the corner is it
not yeah it is um this exciting time for
you because when I got last year I
thought it was almost I thought it was
like pretty much about you guys have
done a whole another year of Polish I
know I know it's a beautiful game do it
don't be a shame you be proud of how
polish this game is we're gonna take a
look at it right now it's got a really
nice story it's kind of intro it it's
just a really pretty game so let's go
ahead okay
now in rive you're like one of the
wonderful parks but is that you kind of
get to become multiple different
machines your one thing but there's all
these different modes that you get to
play mmhmm yeah well basically it's a
shooter platformer that was inspired by
a lot of the games that were telling my
partner and I played in the 90s so we
opened up this area and like an
asteroids great your style yeah it looks
like a shmup right now like it's kind of
a like kill everything that you see it's
got great particle effects it's just a
canary stunning beautiful game but then
bread is you get oh and the great is you
probably get adjusted to that the game
kind of switches it up on you and it
keeps changing which I think makes this
game stand out yeah okay so this area is
mostly for people to get to know to
controls a little bit so it's a
twin-stick shooter and the game will
open up throughout this demo
and then one of the different things on
the screen that people should know about
its kind of gauge of what you're hitting
in like two times three times your hits
and something like that give a life
gauge as well yeah we do but I think we
might be in god mode here because i
already got hit but it doesn't show it's
being nice to you this is the demo yeah
that's going to be interesting i did all
of a sudden now we're not flying anymore
we are kind of like a little nice little
spider Walker now at this point yeah we
have gravity now and this guy is
welcoming me in the ship into the sugar
tea you don't like him I can just shoot
him if I want you but I actually need
him to open his door um so hopefully yes
kid can't get rid of him that easy huh a
new level missile in the story is that
like a burly mechanic dude is he in
there or is he controlling it from no
he's use the inside ship normally we
would have like an introduction that she
owes you that but for this demo I'm just
playing and now what are you collecting
as well like your yeah we just call him
nuts and bolts okay um you used them to
upgrade your worship
for an excuse can see that at the end of
each level that you get to upgrade or M
it's you cruised through like a really
big starship and every time you get to a
certain area you get there multiple
times so you can upgrade your weapon so
in this case we introduced the hacking
elements so there's a hack mode which
looks a little bit like Terminator broke
I mean you can actually scan and hack
things in your environment and in this
case the door will open down here and I
can actually enter the starship
so there you go all right so a little
bit of fireworks oh it's beautiful
thanks so this is our mission log so
there's a story here as well and
basically you follow this guy who wants
to collect nuts and bolts mmm and you
get stuck into the shipping and the
little robot that welcomes you it will
join you throughout the story and it
will become soil of your friend sort of
your enemy so it's all one linear story
so in this case we just finished mission
1 and now we're going to see where my
next mission is how many missions are
there we have about 12 missions right
now okay and the starship is like
divided into different sections and here
I'm standing on top of a war plateau and
once I activate it will be able to get
back there the next time so I'll just go
here grab a weapon
are these random or will you always get
the same weapon well you can actually
buy it because you now collected eleven
hundred and eighty-five nuts and bolts
alright that sounds like a lot and so
here we get the four main weapons you
can choose between homing missiles sort
of like bouncing grenades I don't have
any gravity okay shotgun and a Tesla
attack which electrocutes you're a nice
game yeah okay so what's your favorite
show me it looks I think the Kessler
attack okay because it looks nice and it
makes a strange noise
so I'm not braiding okay so and I can
test it out here these are just
mechanical bets but I can use my
secondary fire two fire great and these
things just bounce off of everything and
it can have multiple so it can be really
chaotic I'm in addition to just like
regular enemies there are larger
phosphate so we're yes yeah we gotta
like to boss fights before the final
boss right yeah and I won't be able to
get to the first one in this demo but
it's like a one-third two-thirds and at
the end of the game okay so now we're
here at the work machine ok and this
machine basically transports you to
other places in the ship and you get
here like maybe six times and
each time you go to a new section and it
said something about the voice acting
will have full voice acting at the end
but because we're still development
developing the game we only have it now
for the introduction okay so and it's
voy seconds by a guy named Mark Dolson
and he actually did force acting for
Star Wars afore gremlins as well oh
really we're pretty I'm the right
lessons I think he's a gremlin no way
the actual gremlin yeah in Star Wars I
think he is the the small guy next to
Jabba the Hutt's like the Muppets yeah
yeah that's amazing a little evil he
actually look like a gremlin too oh yeah
muscle ministy like then I was a stick
with typecasted yeah and what about your
music music is done by sonic picnic it's
a dutch shell studio and its a mix of
like techno old school like 60 good
music mm-hmm a little bit of dubstep
this hell yeah well it's a really nice
mix though because the theme is pretty
fast paced it doesn't rush you by any
means but there's constantly things
happening and moving and there's a lot
of visual action on the screen
especially when it's in any kind of
shmoop mode you want like some kind of
nice beat going on it's a good choice ok
cool but glad you like it and this is a
little bit of a sad note but this is
you've been putting in the news that
this week this is it this is your final
game this will be our final game yes so
right before i continue about that this
I just collected a hack and now I can
hack dis health book okay um and he'll
follow me around he's gonna heal you yes
so whenever I get into trouble like this
he'll come over and it'll heal me with
his beam and I'll be able to continue
without having lost any health sweet and
no does he have a cool down or
how long does he keep doing that ya
doing continuously forever no you can
anneal like now he's out of I know mo
view power you like mo heal and I can
still kill him and get more help Oh
nobody was healing yet yeah he wasn't
very useful I'm sorry Caleb okay so I'll
just continue here oh so but yes we
decided that this would be our last game
we've been making games for 15 years
already yes and maybe it's time for
something on something else and we don't
know what it's going to be yeah but rice
is going to be our last game so it's
going to be interesting format I know
myself yeah and you did say in your
report not only is it you're laughing
you think it's it's definitely like the
best oh yeah chasing your guys's skills
like you're very proud of this yes yes
we're honest I mean we wanted to spend
like six to nine months on it and it's
already been two years well that like
the standard developer story yeah I like
we're gonna this will be a nice
six-month project uh-huh well it wasn't
but we just want to make sure that is
perfect and held on how large is your
team it's just the three people at
tomorrow's yeah one guy doing the design
that's me one guy doing the programming
and one guy doing the artwork in the
music was done by a lot of not a
computer but it is incredible
I mean it is a very good-looking game
fresh the crew just a small team yeah
well if you spend enough time on
anything becomes pretty so yeah more
more particles Norfolk yes always more
and more more and how long would you say
the game is um I would say you would
spend about six to eight hours to go
through the normal campaign mode mm-hmm
just rushed through is there anything
else besides campaign yes we also have
speed run mode and we have the signal
light single life mode and a brutal
notes as well
is it single life mode already brutal
with brutal matters brutal other means
that your bullets do less damage you get
almost no health drops okay so you
actually have to know what you're doing
quite a bit more than a normal mode and
this is already normal it's really
chaotic and hectic like doesn't by any
means seem to be a walk in the park no
no we don't do easy
almost at the end now well you upgrade
to any other abilities will you just be
getting new different types of guns yeah
you got the guns that you can purchase
and basically the heck's that you
collect are also upgrades because the
enemies that you encounter you can
actually use them to your advantage so
the health will Till's me but i can also
hector us that's in the next level that
I don't think last time for that but you
can actor it's until increase your
firepower or you can get sort of like a
dog that actually attacks others and
follows you around so actually your
skills will are expanded by the heck's
that you collect oh man it's a stressful
yeah okay
can I do that sometimes I felt oh damn
it you're dead yeah we did a good job
thank you so much for showing me that
was arrived yes it was and when can
people expect to see that again in
September September or today because
we're also part of the humble weekly
bundle okay and it has for the first
time I think from the mix event there
will be demos available and people can
purchase it now they will also get a
free are there thirty three percent off
coupon okay when it launches so you did
want to try and play today you can
actually do that through humble bundle
yes you can awesome one I think 10 more
games as well in the bundle so it's
really yeah that's really cool that
sounds are in it is with typical humble
bundle is it pay yeah pay what you want
and stuff goes to charity as well well
you really can't beat that so pay what
you want for 10 games including the demo
for rive which will give you thirty
three percent off the final game when it
comes out in September so thank you very
much calm okay thanks for every
you